yo what is up everybody mad Luigi here
with a Dark Souls 3 tutorial video on
this video I'm gonna be showing you guys
how to improve and upgrade the estus
flask so that you can take more Suites
from it and each so we regens more HP
and fe all the stuff i'm doing this
video carries over to the ash and Estus
flask however i never use the ashen
Estus flask so this video will only be
showing the normal SS flask so to do
this you're going to need two items
you're going to need the undead bone
shard and the estus flask shard or the s
discharge for short both of these items
can be found throughout the world you'll
see me picking up one of each inside
this video however I'm not going to be
listing locations because that would
take a while that'd be like a whole
separate video so you guys want that I
will make that but it won't be included
in this video
so once you have both of these items
you're going to take them to finally try
and use them in two different ways to
upgrade your SS last both are pretty
simple
the first one for the estus shard the
estus flask shard you're gonna take to
andre the blacksmith so if hopefully you
haven't killed them and you're going to
go down to his fifth line you're gonna
say reinforce Estus flasks and however
many shards you have he will reinforce
it each time you ask them to until you
run out this will give you more charges
however I don't think it resets until
you go rest at a bonfire that's good
because you're going over to the bonfire
for the next step which is using the
undead bone shards so go to the Firelink
shrine bonfire go to the fourth line and
it'll ask you if you want to burn the
undead bone shards I think that's what
it says I plan the Japanese version so
I'm not exactly sure what it says but go
to the fourth line say okay and then you
would get a little number next year
Estus flask showing that it is now
improved in efficiencies every swing you
take will regen more HP or FB and since
you resting at the bonfire you should
notice now that your number of charges
has gone up if you went to andre the
blacksmith and got your Estus flask
shards translate it into more charge so
that's basically it for the video it is
pretty quick it's pretty simple thing to
do if you guys want a video detailing
locations for these things then I'm more
than happy to make it I found quite a
few not all of them but I think a good
amount so if you guys want that I will
make a video more in depth on that hope
you guys enjoyed make sure you stick
around my channel if you want more Dark
Souls 3 content since I'm going to be
making a lot of Dark Souls 3 videos
because there's a lot of stuff in the
game no it's hard game a lot of people
need tutorials I need tutorials for a
lot of the stuff so I'm happy to give
you guys the knowledge that I had
alright guys see you later peace out bye